the creative moment is when you get
Beyond yourself when you dissociate from
everything known in your Material World
Turns out when you do that and you start
changing your brain waves your brain
waves slow down into Alpha and Theta
you're suppressing the memory bank of
the known self that keeps you plugged
into three-dimensional reality when you
quiet down this mechanism now all of a
sudden you start connecting to that
field and when you can stay conscious in
those subconscious Realms when you can
literally regulate and change brain
waves now you're in the operating system
where you can make those significant
changes so we now know that when people
apply the formula and they do that
properly now they're walking through
that door where they're ready to create
from in other words you can do it it's
just going to take a long time but when
you create from the field instead of
from matter there's a whole different
set of dynamics that takes place and why
not push that envelope to see okay if
we've done this is it possible to do
this as an example so the person who's
healed themselves of some health
condition when it comes time to heal
somebody else they're gonna say well now
we understand the science I understand
how this all works now they witness a
significant change in a person's body in
real time right there hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how it
can align with our source enjoy
rule number two understand who you are
with Wayne Dyer if you would like to
accomplish something
you must first expect it of yourself
and my question to you is
what do you expect of yourself
do you expect to be able to perform
miracles to attract into your life the
kind of prosperity that you are entitled
to do you expect that you can manifest
the kind of relationships that you would
like
in order to be able to
have these kinds of expectations for
yourself you have to make a dramatic
change a dramatic shift you must change
what's possible for you
and what you believe is possible for you
but the question becomes
who am I
you know I've been teaching Philosophy
for 40 years now either at the high
school level or Junior High School level
or university level graduate school and
now in stages all over the world and in
front of audiences such as this watching
at home
and here this evening
who are you
and what is real
my teacher in India's name was
nisargadata Maharaja
he was asked the question
Swami what is real master what is real
and his response was
that is real
which never changes
so what part of you
is Real by that definition
who are you
that never changes
so many of us believe that we are our
bodies
I don't know about you but
this body that I'm in right now is
changing all the time very fast as a
matter of fact in fact I Wayne Dyer the
eye that is I
have been in many many bodies
since I incarnated for this first time
here on this planet right here 71 years
ago and I have been in toddler bodies
baby bodies teenage bodies Macho bodies
mustache bodies
endless bodies I have been in with my
little ones and my eight children and
the fact of it is that when you think
about it when I was in the 20 year old
body that I was in
I really thought it was real
didn't you I mean even the body that you
and all of you look at your body and
think well let's see I was in a 20 year
old body and is it real was it real well
you believed that it was real
but I've been looking for that 20 year
old body for 50 years now
I can't find it and the fact of it is
the body that you're in right now is not
who you are because it doesn't meet that
fundamental definition of what is real
what is real is what never changes the
fact is that who you are keeps occupying
new bodies every single moment that you
are here on this planet
it was a great poet her name was Emily
Dickinson I feel like she was must have
been a sister
soul mate of mine she once had a poem
she said holding up a handful of dust
she would reach down and say
this quiet dust
was gentlemen
and ladies and Lads and girls
was laughter
and ability and sighing and frocks and
curls
this passive place a summer's Nimble
Mansion where Bloom and bees fulfilled
their Oriental circuit then ceased
like these
that's who all of us are if we identify
ourselves with our body the fact is that
everything in this physical universe
doesn't meet the definition of what is
real who you are is that soul that I
spoke about a few moments ago that soul
that says
I want to expand I want to be free I
want to go to a place where I understand
that who I am is birthless deathless
changeless and live from that place
because
[Music]
what this involves fundamentally is
reprogramming yourself
from the belief system that has been
your ego it's a part of us that has come
to believe that who we are is what we
have
and who we are is what we do
and who we are is what other people
think of us like our reputation and who
we are is separate from each other and
most egregiously who we are is separate
from God from our source
and so we've been raised and taken out
into the world and said go out there and
prove Who You Are
by achieving by accumulating by getting
other people to like you
foreign
I wrote a book and did a film not too
long ago called the shift and in there I
spoke about and used these words the
direction we take in life
is far more important than the place
that our ego
Parks us
in this present moment that who we are
is this Divine
infinite being that keeps occupying new
bodies endlessly until we leave this
body and then move on and there is no
beginning
there is no end there is only now each
and every one of us so the soul
the part of you that is extraordinary
the part of you that came into this
world and knows I can be anything I can
do anything I can accomplish anything
that I place my attention on rule number
three is channel your Spirit guides with
Gabby Bernstein right now I'm sitting in
my apartment and I've lived in this
apartment for more than a decade I'm
moving next week which is so sad to me
it's exciting but it's sad and the
biggest reason it's sad is because I've
spent so much time in this apartment
channeling connecting to Spirit
connecting to a deep inner knowing a
presence of a spiritual connection
Beyond me and right up there in my loft
my little zenden that I've used for a
decade is where I would sit meditate
listen to music place my hand on my
heart had crystals around me beautiful
beautiful pillows and affirmations and a
shrine and in that space I just began to
develop this great spiritual connection
so I wanted to share with you some of
the ways that I've experienced these
spiritual Connections in my meditation
and I want you to know what those
connections can come through like so
that when you are meditating and you are
channeling you can actually be aware of
what's going on
so here's the first sign that you're
channeling
you feel a presence of Peace come over
you this absolute settling of your
nervous system you feel at ease relaxed
and connected I often have my hands
going up and they almost move at times
and they feel almost hot as if I'm
holding energy as if I'm holding a ball
of energy actually another sign you're
channeling you feel a chill go down your
spine or you feel Goosebumps on your
arms that's absolutely a sure sure sign
that you are calling in an energy beyond
your own
and I love this one you can often feel a
sense that there is an inner voice and
it can often be Audible for some people
but in my case it actually felt like I
was reading a book but listening to the
author in the background I'm not sure if
you've had that experience while you're
reading you can actually get a sense
that you're listening to an author or
listening to a voice of somebody else
that's how I know that there's this
amazing presence coming through because
I can start to sense that there's a
download coming that there's a voice
coming through and it's not a voice
that's my own it often sounds very
ethereal and it sounds very loving and
soothing and connected and guided and
it's very spiritual in nature and then
what happens for me particularly is I
start speaking really fast so if I'm
channeling for somebody else and I don't
realize it quite yet I'll still feel
those chills come down my spine my hands
will go numb I'll start hearing that
background noise of a voice behind me
and then I start speaking really fast
and that fast speech becomes this
full-blown experience of allowing the
Spirit to move through me so if any of
these specific things have happened to
you don't freak out please don't freak
out trust that it is a beautiful skill
we all have the ability to channel some
of us it's more natural just like
someone who plays the piano and they've
been practicing for years and for some
of us it takes more time to practice and
develop the skill set of being able to
release all of the noise in your
Consciousness so that you can allow the
subconscious frequency of spirit to move
through you this is so powerful once you
start to begin to develop these methods
in your own life because you can start
to receive inner wisdom you receive
inner guidance and what is it that
you're hearing from you're hearing from
that spiritual connection that is within
you and around you Spirit guides
inspiration the voice of Love is already
in you and these guides are bringing it
to you as a direct line of communication
to remind you of what you already know
so next time you sit in your meditation
just go deeper and allow yourself to
really develop that presence of Peace
within I want to help you with this as
well I have developed a very deep
practice of meditation and meditation is
the portal through which that spiritual
connection comes through
so I want you to join me if you are up
for it on a 21 day meditation challenge
where I'll be your meditation coach
taking you through the steps of how to
develop that meditative state so that
you can be a channel to receive
spiritual guidance far beyond your logic
or your reason or your thinking and my
hope is that in the 21 days you'll start
to develop a repetitive pattern that not
only serves you and relaxes you and
makes you really elevated so that you
become a super attractor in every area
of your life but also gives you that
direct line to spiritual connection so
that you too can claim your ability to
be a channel for presence of Love within
you and around you also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you use space
to write down what your key takeaways
are and your specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet design specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number four
clear negative energy with Jack Canfield
today scientists know that everything
found in the universe is made up of
energy this goes for both physical and
non-physical objects of course basic
physics and chemistry tells us that a
physical object such as a building a
tree or a book is made up of billions of
individual atoms like energy bundles
that interact and bond with other atoms
into many forms including water metal
plants soil plastic wood pulp and other
raw materials used to manufacture
physical objects
non-physical things including thoughts
are also made up of energy and can also
Bond and interact with aspects and
objects of our physical world
it's well known for instance that our
brain waves are a form of intense energy
that can be easily detected with
standard medical equipment and that can
interact with our physical world as any
other form of energy would now perhaps
you're wondering what do I mean by
interact with our physical world
have you ever thought about a distant
friend only to get a phone call from
them a minute later
have you ever driven down a highway
wondering whether you'll get a speeding
ticket only to see flashing red lights
in your rear view mirror a second later
that's your brain waves interacting with
your physical reality luckily it's also
possible to use your thoughts to
intentionally create the positive
results you want in your life
now if you've ever desired something
intensely for months only to suddenly
receive it through some serendipitous
means or step into a situation where it
was provided to you that was also your
thoughts your intention and your desire
impacting your experience
you see the world as we've created it is
a process of our thinking and it cannot
be changed without changing our thinking
the great physicist Albert Einstein
studied this phenomenon in 1935 when he
experimented with quantum physics the
idea that energetically activating a
particle on one side of the universe
created an instantaneous response in a
partner particle elsewhere in the
universe
Columbia University Professor Brian
Greene explains it this way according to
Quantum Theory and the many experiments
that bear out its predictions the
quantum connection between two particles
can persist even if they are on opposite
sides of the universe
in other words something that happens
over here can be entwined with something
that happens over there
a number of other documented experiments
have also proven that thoughts can
rapidly travel through space and either
be picked up by others or have an effect
on physical matter
we also know from polygraph or lie
detector tests that your body reacts to
your thoughts changing your temperature
heart rate blood pressure breathing rate
muscle tension and how much your hand
sweat when you're hooked up to a lie
detector and are asked a question such
as did you take the money your hands
will get colder your heart will beat
faster your blood pressure will go up
your breathing will get faster your
muscles might get tighter and your hands
might sweat if you take if you did take
the money and you lie about it now these
kinds of physiological changes occur not
only when you're lying but also in
reaction to every single thought you
think every cell in your body is
affected by every thought you have
now negative thoughts affect your body
negatively weakening you making you
sweat and making you up tight positive
thoughts affect your body in a positive
way making you more relaxed more
centered more open and alert
positive thoughts cause the secretion of
endorphins in the brain and reduce pain
and increase pleasure
psychiatrist Daniel G Ayman has named
the limiting thoughts we hear in our
head ants
ants automatic negative thoughts and
just like real ants at a picnic your
ants can ruin your experience of life
Dr Ayman recommends that you learn to
Stomp The Ants first you have to become
aware of them next you have to shake
them off and stomp them by challenging
them and finally you have to replace
them with more positive affirming
thoughts the key to dealing with any
kind of negative thinking is to realize
that you're ultimately in charge of
whether to listen to and agree with any
thought or to not now just because you
think it or hear it doesn't mean it's
true you want to constantly ask yourself
is this thought helping me or is this
thought hurting me is it getting me
closer to where I want to go or is it
taking me further away is it motivating
me to action or is it blocking me with
fear and self-doubt
you have to learn the challenge and talk
back to the thoughts that are not
serving you and creating greater success
and happiness
my friend Doug bench recommends writing
down every negative thought you think or
say out loud and every negative thought
you hear anyone else say for three whole
days
make sure that two of those days are
work days and that one of those days is
a weekend day
now ask your spouse or your partner your
children roommates fellow employees to
catch you whenever you have a negative
thought and impose a dollar fine on you
when they hear you uttering that
negative thought in a recent five-day
Workshop I conducted I have participants
put two dollars in a bowl every time
they said anything that was blaming
justifying self-criticizing or
self-negating it was amazing to see how
fast that bowl filled up however is the
five days went on there were fewer and
fewer automatic negative comments as
everybody became much more aware and
much more intentional
now what if you could learn to always
talk to yourself like a winner instead
of a loser what if you could transform
your negative self-talk into positive
self-talk what if you could silence your
thoughts of lack and limitation and
replace them with thoughts of abundance
and unlimited possibility
what if you could replace any victim
language in your thoughts with the
language of empowerment
and what if you could transform your
inner critic who judges your every move
into a supportive inner coach who would
encourage you and give you confidence as
you face new situations and risks
you see the good news is that all of
this is possible with a little awareness
focus and intention
now here's your homework to complete
after watching this video
I want you to write down every negative
thought that you have for the next three
days
the results may surprise you
and as you become more aware of your
negative comments and thoughts you'll be
able to clear your negative energy
finally I want you to answer this
what is your most common negative
thought
is that I can't
I'm not good enough
if I do that I'll fail
it's not safe to say what I really think
it's too dangerous to stand up for what
I believe and then what I'd like you to
do is think of what's the opposite
thought that you could choose to think
instead of that negative thought rule
number five is reprogram your mind with
Bruce Lipton what do you think the
differences are then between the the
conscious and the subconscious mind and
I know you've mentioned that that's the
game that's the most important whole
question you just asked there right now
Louis for this reason the subconscious I
said is the equivalent of a hard drive
on a computer it can run the show you
push start it could do things you don't
have to even attend to it it does it by
itself
the conscious mind is the equivalent of
who's typing on the keyboard because
you're the one that's putting
information into this thing the
conscious mind and here's important part
let's just start with this
the mind is controlling our biology
that's a fact now I go but when you say
the mind it sounds like oh there's one
mind I go now that is where it goes
wrong because there are two minds and
they they both have different functions
and most importantly they learn in
different ways what are the two minds
well let's start with the latest
Evolution right behind your forehead is
a lump of brain called prefrontal cortex
the seat of self-consciousness I am an
individual I am separate from all other
individuals I am a self and I'm you know
coming from this creative part the
subconscious mind as we mentioned that's
just the hard drive with programs in it
so I say so what's the difference
between it well first thing is this what
makes human so different than other
organisms is the self-conscious or
conscious mind because it's creative it
has imagination I could ask you right
now Louis I can tell you I could ask you
a question I say tell me what you want
out of your life
well at that moment you're going to
think and you're going to say you know I
want this and I want that and I go well
that came from the conscious mind now
it's creative that has imagination that
has vision and if you have a a vision
you can then manifest a vision if you
you can't manifest a vision if you don't
have a vision so your conscious mind
sets up Visions in what we want
but here's the point
um and this is the the critical the
whole thing is on this one part right
now Louis right here not assist the
conscious mind which is the creative
mind versus subconscious mind which is
the Habit mine it does habits as does as
program programs I have it push the
button play the program push the button
Play It Again push it please again okay
program conscious mind Creator okay and
I go okay significance of that is that's
where your wishes and desires are what
do you want oh man I want this I want a
great relationship I want a great job I
want great health you know you creative
the subconscious mind programs primarily
derived from other people before age
seven okay and unfiltered so there are
good programs and there are bad programs
okay uh and I go so
creative conscious mind is the one that
gives you a destination and a future
subconscious mind just gives you
autopilot
okay back to the Crux of the problem
only five percent of the day is the
conscious mind actually an Engaged in
creating
and I go then what's it doing 95 I get
95 of the day it's thinking like so what
does that mean I go imagine your body's
vehicle steering wheel conscious is uh
holding a wheel and driving us to wear
wishes and desires man okay I say but if
I start thinking then conscious mind is
no longer looking out because thinking
is inside it's a thought on the inside I
said well if you're thinking then
conscious mind is not looking out I go
well what if you're driving the car and
then you start thinking I go
conscious mind let go of the wheel I
said oh my God I go don't worry why
subconscious mind is autopilot whatever
you're not controlling with your
conscious mind subconscious mind throws
a program in and does it okay now the
issue about that is well if the
conscious mind is thinking is it
observing what's going on I go no to
observe what's going on it has to look
out the window can't be looking inside
so 95 of the day it doesn't even observe
your own behavior I said but where's
that behavior coming from I go the
program I go but yeah but where did that
come from I go somebody else
well if they didn't put your wishes and
desires into their life then you copied
their program you're you're not going
toward your wishes and desires going to
wherever their program is going to
that's how children follow in the
footpath of their parents especially
like musicians a musician who's a parent
during the programming of Their Own
Child instills them with all the music
and stuff like that then a child grows
up and guess what now they're a musician
people the music Gene I go there's no
music Jane there was training first
seven years training to be that so the
issue is
95 of our life is not coming from wishes
and desires it's coming from programs
which came from other people and you
don't see it when it's happening and I
go why not and I said why are you
playing a program because I'm not paying
attention I go well that's why you don't
see the program and I go and then 95 of
your life is programmed and then the
relevance about that is 60 of those are
disempowering or self-sabotaging or
limiting beliefs so it says then 95 of
the day you're running your life and
you're the only one that doesn't see it
I go well that's the big issue I go the
same story for 40 years that's been in
all my videos but I got to do it again
because different audience here yeah you
have a friend you know your friends
Behavior very very well you're really
you know good friends and you happen to
know your friend's parent
and one day you see your friend has the
same behavior as their parents so you
know you gotta you gotta tell hey Bill
you're just like your dad back away from
Bill I know exactly what Bill's going to
say all the time Bill's going to say how
can you compare me to my dad I'm nothing
like my dad the audience laughs why
they're familiar with it I go that you
want the profound story of the day
that's the profound story I go what does
it mean everybody else can see that bill
it behaves like his dad the only one who
can't see it is Bill
explain it simple yeah
Bill downloaded these programs from his
dad yep when does he play him when he's
thinking am I saying how much of that I
say 95 of the day I say does he see the
program I say no thinking is inside he's
not working out and so Bill's the only
one that doesn't see it and he got it
from somebody else and so it's not his
behavior and he could be sabotaging
himself and he's the only one that can't
see it because why because he's thinking
and I go okay you ready all of us are
Bill
right all of us every day are Bill we're
playing the same programs we look at
life going oh man that's not what I
wanted I would oh this is not really
good and I go where's this coming from
well those people are causing this
people are causing I go
no you're the Creator didn't see what
you were creating with and when we get
personal awareness of this then personal
empowerment is the next step because now
it's like well if I'm doing this then
I'm the one that can change it I go
absolutely
absolutely that's what the whole point
is and this is why you're you know all
your programs for the wish are so
involved with wake up people it's time
to take the power back and become what
you want to be in this life because you
don't realize you're playing programs
that are sabotaging you all day long and
you don't see it you're the only one and
remember six the last time before some
very special bonus Clips is become aware
with Eckhart Tolle
and my question is
um
when I try to maintain presence in my
everyday life I'm aware that my
subconscious need for superiority
sabotages me pretty regularly and it
happens very often so I wonder what
suggestions you have
it would be nice for us to have one or
two examples of how that looks
I was afraid you would ask that
um well typically when
um like this morning someone approached
me and they were anxious and worried and
off balance and I thought
it's sort of an automatic thing sort of
you know why don't you get your act
together and rather than just having a
positive Exchange
and then I notice of course when I'm
anxious or off balance I want everybody
to be kind and understanding so it's uh
I judge that is not a good thing I would
like to be more automatically kind
okay
one more example perhaps one more
um
okay when my question was chosen and I
was invited to be here
I was really excited about that and
um it was tempting to think and it was
kind of my first thought that oh isn't
this wonderful
I have this great question but
um
you know I quickly realized that in
reality that's
uh it might be a pertinent question but
it's not about me and it's not I mean it
doesn't mean that I'm great okay
so it seems like a constant fight for me
yeah
well of course it's very normal that
kind of uh mind activity it's just as
awareness arises it seems to be more of
a problem than it would be for a
normally unconscious person now the good
thing is that the awareness is there of
it if you were totally
unconscious that is identified with
those thought patterns you wouldn't even
know it because the essence of
identification is you don't know it you
are it you are the thought so you would
then instead of
feeling Superior and realizing that you
feel Superior and then not wanting to
feel Superior you would just feel
Superior
and that would be really unconscious
and that would be quite normal
now as because awareness arises
it's a good thing you're aware of
certain mind patterns subtle things
where you feel
Superior or special so it's it's another
word for it that's a specialness
uh because specialist doesn't Superior
almost implies better than
specialness could also be
I'm much worse off than you that's why
I'm so special my problems are much
bigger than yours don't tell me about
your problems let me tell you about mine
or as my dad used to say
when people said I have a headache or
whatever egg that you have a headache
I've had a headache for weeks
foreign
that's not so much superiority but well
in a way it is it's specialness I'm more
special than you because I have more
headaches than you
I must be more interesting for them
the reasoning behind it is it's
irrational of course
so awareness is there which is a
decisive Factor it has come in the
awareness is aware of that mind pattern
then however the awareness is obscured
Again by an additional mind pattern that
says I shouldn't be having these swords
which are more thoughts
so we have three things here in
operation there's the original thought
pattern harmless as it may be but
there's a recognition of the thought
pattern which comes from the fact that
there's awareness through awareness the
thought pattern is recognized
but then
the Mind comes in again it uses the
awareness the recognition that arose
through awareness
to construct
an additional level of problems which is
I shouldn't be having those thoughts I'm
not a good person anymore if I have
those thoughts I'm not kind if I have
those thoughts and what is that thoughts
so it can happen that as awareness
arises which is a wonderful thing you're
not totally identified with the Mind
pattern anymore
and then the mind is so cunning
that out of that recognition it creates
new mind patterns
and the new mind patterns say
I'm not a kind person if I think that I
mustn't think I feel bad about thinking
that I shouldn't by now I should be rid
of that whatever it says
so the that's where you have to be
careful to become aware that the mind
has come in again after the awareness
that is not necessary but you didn't
know that that was unconscious
so the mind has little it's very cunning
you recognize the minds there
and then the Mind comes back in again
and uses your recognition to manufacture
more thought out of that
[Music]
right
and this is why it's very good to ask
that question
it helps everybody so you are special
everybody has similar problems so we are
all special
the that's where you once you're aware
of that you can then recognize that as
unnecessary you don't need that it's
Superfluous mind activity that does
nothing except strengthen your mind
so and then you can simply allow the
recognition to be there without the
additional
mental judgment
of let's say something wrong with you
and that in itself gradually dissolves
the power of the Mind pattern all you
need is the awareness of what your mind
is doing then gradually what your mind
is doing becomes less
dense less powerful and the awareness
grows so there's a shrinking of the Mind
pattern and the growing of the awareness
the only way the mind can stop that
pattern is by as I said by coming in
after the awareness and creating more
thought around
that so just be happy with being aware
it's a mind pattern it's nothing to do
with who you are
you don't you're not an unkind person
you're not whatever the mind says it's
just this that mind pattern isn't that
interesting
there it is and that is in itself
sufficient
first of all every time we have a
thought we make a chemical and and if
you have uh an unlimited thought you
will feel unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits that signal another part
of the brain to release peptides or
chemical Messengers that signal hormonal
centers and when we get that arousal
from the thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
turns out that the emotions that are
created from the thoughts are the
signaling mechanisms of the body
thoughts of the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel uh
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones based in survival
those are the thoughts that begin to
push the genetic buttons that create
disease in other words a person wakes up
in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems and those problems
are memories that are etched in the
brain that are connected to certain
people certain objects certain things at
certain times and places so if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny the
moment you think about your problems
you're thinking in the past right now
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems now you feel
unhappy now you feel anxious now you
feel fear so the moment we feel those
emotions it takes a thought and a
Feeling
a memory or an image an emotion a
stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion and the emotion
that person's fabricating by thought
alone the body's believing it's in that
environmental condition
so if the environment signals the Gene
and that's the truth and the end product
of an experiences in the environment is
an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is the brain
checks in with the body and says yeah
you're feeling pretty miserable you're
suffering and we tend to generate more
thoughts equal to the feeling that we
have
and so then we get caught in this Loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking then we're thinking in the past
right and so we call that
The Familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh I gotta see this person I got to go
to that meeting I hate doing this and
now they get in their routine and a
habit is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will to a set of programs
right so now you have the familiar past
and you have the predictable future
those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is The Sweet Spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts people
start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and an emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined and so then when you're
releasing all of these chemicals we are
literally drawing the body's life force
and turning it into chemistry and so for
the short term that's cool but the
arousal that's created from those stress
hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems and
the conditions in their life to reaffirm
their conditioning or their addiction to
that emotion and in a sense they become
addicted to the life they don't even
like and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay I'm not
going to say I can't I'm not going to
judge another person I'm not going to
blame I'm not going to complain I'm not
going to make excuses I'm not going to
be a victim I'm not going to talk trash
about anybody I'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
then the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just gonna stop
today so now the body which has been
conditioned emotionally to be the Mind
wants to return back to its familiar
territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on this is a
good time to judge that come on this is
a good time to suffer it's your ex's
fault it's your it's the government's
fault it's uh you know it's the weather
what the news whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those Pharmacy of
chemicals and so that's when the person
makes the same Choice does the same
thing creates the same experience just
for that familiar feeling okay I'll
complain just so I can feel suffering
then they'd rather be unhappy than step
into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choices you did day before and here's
the payoff
you got to stay conscious and not go
unconscious and it turns out that 95 of
the time we're unconscious so if you're
going to stay conscious then there's an
element that also requires a certain
amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
I can't it's too hard my life will never
change at someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
becomes aware of how they speak and how
they act and they notice how they're
feeling and they're no longer the
program they're the Consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
they're they're when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and you're tweeting
and your Instagraming and Facebook and
whatever people do you're distracted by
that feeling
but I now know that if you take a person
and you say Okay close your eyes sit in
the in the Silence of any external
stimulation remove the environment sit
your body down like an animal body is
the animal tell it to stay I'm gonna
feed you you can check your cell phone
you can shower you can have your coffee
but when I say
and so then Here Comes The Challenge
right so and and then if you say then
you're not going to live in The Familiar
future familiar past or predictable
future you're not going to think about
how long you've been meditating what you
got to do you you labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say I
think I'm meditating wrong I always say
oh no no you're doing it right because
when you notice that your body wants to
get up and check your cell phone or have
a cup of coffee and you become aware
that it's on autopilot and wants to do
that and you say come on over here and
you return it back to the present moment
you're executing a will now that's
greater than the program and if the
person wants to just get angry while
they're sitting there there's an arousal
and they notice the body is amping up
and revving up and they settle it back
down now they're telling the body it's
no longer the mind
a third of mine now we've researched
this
and it's tedious in the beginning at
first because David is fighting Goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner and later the body is trained to
a new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life and
they're they're working and lowering the
volume to that emotion the more they
lower the volume of that emotion the
more they're going to take their
attention off that person and problem
and they're going to take their power
back there's going to be a break and
their attention from that circumstance
and now they build their own field and
now there's energy to heal now there's
energy to create a new life now there's
energy for the mystical moment because
they've overcome their old personality
self so
I think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming overcoming overcoming
overcoming until we become somebody else
many people come to me and say I want to
be a millionaire I I and there's a great
song about I'm going to be a millionaire
and they read things like the secret
which says if you want to be a
millionaire just just wish it and it
will happen and that's not quite enough
I've worked with many many many
millionaires and I became on myself
quite a long time ago now never having
possibly thought that could ever happen
when I was at school I was going to be a
nanny that's how much I thought I could
earn in my lifetime that's what I
thought I was meant to be
but then I worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
I really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth I'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there are several things that will stop
you here's the number one you don't
believe you are worth it you may want
money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says I'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of that so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must decide
you're worth it the more reasons you can
decide you're worth it the more you'll
have that motivation that fire that
drive to go out and make a lot of money
the second thing that will make you
become and stay a millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
Bill Gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years malaria won't exist
because he is using his money to wipe
out malaria that's an extraordinary
thing and he deserves all the wealth he
has for that reason alone if you can
think of something that you could do or
the people you would help and impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well I'm
just gonna float around and manifest
Millions I'm just gonna sit at home with
myself and manifest Millions if you want
a job you go out and look for a job if
you want a new home you go out and visit
new homes you want a partner you better
go out and put yourself in front of
people and if you want to make and keep
Millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do to make those Millions what gift or
Talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say that I don't have anything
but that's not true if you really take a
while you can find a gift a unique skill
set you have that you could monetize you
see some of the smartest people in the
world they don't invent a product they
take an existing product like James Dice
and he took a hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
clean he took a hand dryer and he made
them better and many many people take an
existing product to make it better and
become a millionaire that way it's not
about shall I invent something I don't
have an inventive mind I'm not creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new and Spanx came on the market
and became a multi
multi-million dollar company they didn't
invent a new product well they sort of
did they took an existing product they
made it so much better and you can do
that too but the biggest blocks I see
with budding millionaires are these
things one is I'm going to be a
millionaire I'm going to be a
millionaire and they're just trying to
imagine it in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future Pace very well one of the reasons
depressed people can't snap out of it is
because they can't future paste and by
the way if this is making sense to you
please like please share please
subscribe to my channel and show it to
other people who also want to make money
why wouldn't you want to make money you
can do great things for others when you
make money but they don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and Chan
on Shanty and money will fall from the
heavens we all know that's not true so
if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now you must be
able to think of how you're going to
menu what could you possibly do to make
money remember that woman who changed
the face of a floor mop they made a
movie about her and she became a
millionaire and she was a housewife but
one day she was mopping off you know
this is not really a good morph and she
recreated and reinvented a floor mop and
has made him millions that way but
here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well I just
manifest I just sit at home the best
plan in the world will not work
if you don't work so people get this
really weird belief that people who make
millions don't work they just manifest
it falls from the heavens they float
around doing a little stuff here and
there and that's not true I work with
Millionaires and billionaires and they
do work hard they work long and they
work hard on their way to success they
work a lot when they get success of
course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work I love what I do I do what I love
often say I feel like I've never worked
a day in my life because I love what I
do but really I have worked hard when
I've written books I've been writing for
12 hours a day meeting deadlines I
travel all over the world through time
zones giving talks and sometimes that's
tiring I plan out my schools and I'm
there teaching
but I love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe you can be
a millionaire and not have to change
anything or do anything or work hard you
will probably never be a millionaire you
have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary self-belief and finally
you have to put yourself around other
people who've made money ask them what
did you do what happened to you you see
I met Wayne Dyer many years ago and he
said something he always remembered do
not die with your music Still inside and
I thought wow I'm one of the best
therapists in the world and I can't die
with my therapy I mean I need to create
a course make a school teacher to other
people I was so glad I listened to him
and I've listened to many people who say
the same thing I didn't go to university
I didn't have a charm background I
wasn't born into money but I had a dream
a vision and I married that Vision to
very hard work I kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination so take a few minutes
and just get a little notebook or on
your phone write out all the reasons why
you would like to be a millionaire all
the good things you could do if you were
a millionaire the people you could help
and then decide what industry you could
go into you're going to invent something
create something and some of the
smartest people create things entirely
by mistake look at what other
millionaires have done read some books
written by millionaires there are many
read Richard brandts and read Felix
Dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it I can do it
this is a template and I'm going to
follow that template and if you have the
belief the vision the work ethic the
drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire when we are very little we
learn how to feel about ourselves and
about life by the reactions of the
adults around us
now if you lived with frightened people
or with people who were very unhappy
then you learned a lot of negative
things about yourself and about life
you may still believe them
however this is not to blame our parents
for we are all victims of victims and
they could not possibly have taught us
anything they did not know
if your mother did not know how to love
herself or your father did not know how
to be gentle and kind
then it would be impossible for them to
teach you to love yourself or to be
gentle and kind
your parents were doing the best they
could with what they had been taught as
children
I also believe that we choose our
parents
each one of us decides to Incarnate upon
this planet at particular points in time
and space I believe we do this because
we have chosen to come here to learn a
particular lesson that will advance us
upon our spiritual
evolutionary pathway
we choose our sex our color our country
and then we look around for the
particular set of parents who will
mirror the pattern we are bringing in to
work on in this lifetime
often when we grow up we point our
fingers accusingly at our parents and
whimper you did it to me but really
we chose them because they were perfect
for what we wanted to work on overcoming
as very little children we learn our
belief systems and then we move through
life creating experiences to match our
beliefs
look back in your own life
and notice how often you have gone
through the same experience
well I believe that you created those
experiences over and over
because they mirrored something that you
believed was true about yourself
it really doesn't matter how long we
have had a problem or how big it is
or how life-threatening it is the point
of power is always in the present moment
this means that what you have
experienced during your life and up to
this moment
you have created by your own thoughts
and beliefs of the past
however what you are choosing to think
and believe and say today right here and
right now is creating your future
your current internal dialogue is
creating tomorrow next week next month
next year
Etc
notice what you are thinking at this
moment
do you want this thought to be creating
your future
is it negative or positive
just notice and be aware
I'm not trying to create guilt for
anyone nor to make anyone wrong
I am making us aware of what is going on
inside of us
many of us who create illness and
dis-ease are in fact totally out of
touch with what is going on in our minds
and in our bodies
we only notice our bodies when we become
ill or are in pain
if we do not know what is going on
inside of us how can we ever change
no matter what the problem is
the only thing we are ever dealing with
is a thought
and a thought can be changed
all our experiences are just outer
effects of our inner dialogue
even self-hatred is only hating a
thought you have about yourself
you may have a thought that says I'm a
bad person
this thought produces a feeling and you
accept the feeling as true
however if you eliminate the thought you
won't have the feeling
thoughts can be changed
change the thought and the feeling must
go
believe it or not we do choose our
thoughts
we may habitually think the same thought
over and over so often that it does not
seem that we are choosing the thought
but we did make the original choice
we can refuse to think certain thoughts
look how often you have refused to think
a positive thought about yourself
well you can also refuse to think a
negative thought about yourself
it seems to me that everyone on this
planet that I know or have worked with
is suffering from self-hatred and guilt
to one degree or another
the more self-hatred and guilt we have
the less our life works
we find we have an inability to speak up
for ourselves and we're always trying to
please others
or we may be angry and explosive all the
time
the less self-hatred and guilt we have
the better Our Lives work on all levels
this includes the health of the body too
you need to create an environment of
Excellence Excellence most people's
environments are not excellent the
people around you the the videos that
you watch the things that are on your
wall the voices that are in your head
you have these moments that are bold
that are courageous that make you feel
Unstoppable and you can do anything and
then you fall back down because the
environment is the thing that's keeping
you small it takes a giant effort to
overcome your environment you definitely
can it's definitely possible tons of
people are doing it but it takes that
giant effort to say I don't want to stay
stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year
and if you don't want to stay where you
are right now fast forward to one year
from today you don't want to stay stuck
you want to be in a different place it
could actually be physically moving but
a different place in terms of your
finances in terms of your purpose in
terms of how much you're giving and
caring and sharing and the life that you
want to build you want to be somewhere
totally different like today this is not
acceptable anymore I accept that this is
where I am right now but where I end up
is not going to be the same spot as
where I am right now right if that's
your commitment the biggest shift that
will help you get from where you are now
to where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and the more intense it becomes the more
you're actually living it the faster
you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the people that you look up
to the the whoever of the world like I
want to be the next whoever perfect that
person the more you hang around with
them the more it's going to rub off on
you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now hear and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos I like to see things I
need to be visual if that's you then you
need to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it can
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot events press to help you but if
it's not my channel it's some other
channel one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or the the one
video because that one video on repeat
is gonna lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch it again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good you
watch it the next day and the feeling's
gone so you can't just read the same
book over and over watch the same video
over and over and over again the key is
to find a consistent source so if you
love this channel you love this video
I'm making other videos just like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more
a sense of hope and purpose that you can
do it too you'll start to think more
like him so be careful who you pick and
maybe you don't like Elon Musk maybe you
like Kanye West or Oprah Winfrey or
whoever but the more you're around that
person the more you will start to think
like them so you want to put that as
part of your daily routine that every
day because yesterday was a different
day you might have been fired up bold
motivated great but today's today is a
new day
the motivation you had yesterday is
nowhere near what it is right now when
you wake up
right you can have the best day of all
time you wake up the next day and it's
gone so how do you keep the consistency
the routine
tell yourself I'm going to watch a video
even when I don't want to even when I
feel low energy even when right all the
excuses we come up with I'm going to
watch a video to get myself into the
state I need to get into because I want
to follow I want to follow my dreams I
don't want to be stuck here anymore
tied to that is then subscribe to the
channels
that make you feel that way so do an
audit
of all of the channels you follow on
YouTube of all the people you follow on
Instagram any way you're spending time
on social
do an audit of who makes you actually
feel more bold
and who makes you just waste time
or who makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them
and then the people who make you feel
better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we are designing
our routines around this that I'm going
to watch a video every day with my
heroes so that they pull me forward
right we're putting into our calendar
the second part of it is I'm also going
to subscribe to channels and people that
inspire me so that when I happen to be
on the platforms I'm feeding myself with
things that inspire me and lift me up
instead of waste my time or put me down
okay so that habit that environment
really really matters the second part of
environment to create our environment of
Excellence right is the physical
environment so this office inspires me
this office this was all with intent the
people on the wall behind me we got
Steve Jobs apginini my parents
Howard Schultz Kanye West the trophies
uh you know the YouTube stuff the the
getting
my hands wrong here this side you know
the art the art that people drew my book
uh my neck brace from when I broke my
neck like all even the colors on the
wall all of this it inspires me this
inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself
I see Steve Jobs staring me down I see
my parents staring me down it's like a
reminder of what I want to do because I
wake up and I and I don't have you know
the the most energy I don't feel super
bold and like let's go take on the day
right I don't have that as soon as I
wake up
but we manufacture it through the habits
and routines but also the actual
physical environment and the beauty
about this is you only have to set it up
once you know I set this up once and
then I walk in and every day I'm being
hit with these messages and reminders of
the person that I want to be
so whether that's a mood board you put
up for yourself whether it's people that
inspire you you have to look at the
thing it inspires you to want to push a
little harder it inspires you to want to
believe in yourself and more it inspires
you to want to go off and take some kind
of action today the physical environment
matters a lot and you can control that
so think about think about your office
think about your bedroom think about
your car think about where you're
spending significant time and how much
of that has actually been done with
intent
how much of your physical environment
has been created with intent to make you
believe in yourself more
it matters a lot and then the third
thing really quick is the actual your
outfit the clothes that you wear how you
show up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work that
I want people to believe in themselves
more and I'm going to work when I see
there was a green arrow show I used to
watch
and when they were in their their base
in their Lair they always put their
outfits on a mannequin right so they're
when they're all fighting crime they're
in their uniforms but then when they
come back to their base they they're in
normal clothes but they put their
outfits on a mannequin so I went and got
myself a mannequin it's it's just you
can't see it but it's just sitting here
off camera I got a mannequin and it's
got my hoodie on it as a reminder that
I'm a superhero going to work every day
and again that might sound really cheesy
or dumb or corny but I like it it works
for me and putting this on every day
instead of just showing up in my pajamas
I just I work from home
you know we've got 30 something people
on the team uh I I don't see my team
physically that often most people work
from home I could just show up every day
in my pajamas
but putting this on
reminds me that I'm a superhero with a
mission
and adopt that or not is up to you but
but how present yourself for yourself
not just for the camera I'm not putting
this on just for the camera I'm putting
this on because it's what I put on this
is for me
I could make a video in my pajamas
that's fine but I'm making this for me I
wear this for me what do you need to do
for you not just because there's some
expectations when your expectations of
yourself become higher than what you
think other people's expectations are
for you that's when the game starts to
change when I'm wearing something just
because of how I think you guys will
perceive me or or some speech I'm doing
or some meeting
I'm I'm only living up to that person's
standard to what I think their standards
are and said no I'm doing this for me I
wear this for me I show up like this
even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this because I'm a
superhero going to work and it's my
reminder
this is how you start to create an
environment of Excellence guys your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment is keeping you stuck
and if you don't want to be stuck
anymore if you want to change your
circumstances if you don't want to be in
the same spot you are right now one year
from today you have to create an
environment of Excellence
how do we do that number one we start
feeding our mind with Excellence from
the videos and podcasts and books from
people who Inspire Us number two we
change our physical environment so that
you walk into a room you walk into your
car you walk into your bedroom or office
or wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a superhero
going to work every day because you are
on a mission
you've got a great heart you've got tons
of ideas
I see it over and over and over and over
and over again
so much potential
and just stuck
just stuck
because there's a lack of momentum that
stems from having a really poor
environment
if you can just change with intention
that I am going to create an environment
of Excellence for myself that inspires
me and pushes me forward to step into
the person I want to believe that I can
be
you can do that every day
entire life will change
[Music]
oh I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
amazing one-on-one with Bruce Lipton
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there you don't deserve
that who do you think you are young man
the child Runner 7 isn't thinking oh I'm
not doing well but I'll do better and my
father will be happy I said no child
under seven not thinking recording